with the critical social justice view
we have to believe in these invisible
systems
things like white supremacy patriarchy
heteronormativity
and these permeate everything we're
moving away from
a world where we were promoting equality
of mankind
to one now we're promoting racism i'm
quite scared for america
at the moment i'm afraid that what is
happening is
a genuine attempt at a cultural
revolution and you would have voted for
joe biden i would yes
we're on the opposite side of the aisle
my fear is that it could in its worst
case lead to something that's almost
like a civil war
welcome back to generally speaking i'm
your host general spalling today we have
helen pluck rose
author uh with co-author james lindsey
of the wonderful book
cynical theories helen describes herself
as a liberal humanist so i
probably wouldn't do a very good job of
explaining that i would ask you
helen to explain what is a liberal
humanist
a liberal humanist is somebody who could
um it's not a political side for example
but it's somebody who believes
in um the freedom of the individual
individual liberty um the the ability of
the individual to
understand and evaluate ideas they
believe in humanity is a
a shed a shared experience we have a
common shared humanity
we are made up of of individuals it's a
it's a belief in prioritizing the
potential of the individual to succeed
in our shared society regardless
of their race gender sexuality or any
other
um element of their of their social
existence
so do you believe in the power of the
individual or at least the power
of the individual to choose amongst a
variety of views is that with is that a
fair
way to describe it yes that i i very
much believe that that's
um something that is is highly
criticized by
the theories that i've been writing
about so
and you described yourself as you know
if you were in the u.s of course you're
not
in the u.s you're in east london but if
you were in the us you would be
what we would consider on to be on the
and you would have
voted for uh um
joe biden correct i would i would yes
okay so
the interesting thing about this
conversation is that
i am on the complete other side in terms
of i'm not
on the right i'm more of a libertarian
but i
supported the the campaign or the the
um president trump
so here we find ourselves having a
discussion
about this important subject
but you know on the in terms of
what side of the political aisle each of
us are on we're on the
we're on the opposite side of the aisle
and one of the things
as we were talking that you talked about
was this idea that there is a lot of
essentially alignment between at least
in your view i think that's
what you were saying on the left and the
right in terms of support
for liberal ideas
and when we say liberal here we're
talking about the classical sense of the
word in terms of openness
the power of the individual um human
rights civil liberties rule of law
is that is that a fair statement yes
yes i think so if you if you consider
yourself primarily a libertarian we're
going to have a lot in common um
with beliefs about individual liberty we
if you consider yourself on the right
we'll probably diverge a bit on
economics because i'm not um
very liberal when it comes to economics
so
so but but yeah there's a i think the
majority
of people um both left and right
have respect for that basic concept of
liberalism
of individual liberty of plurality of
people being able to have different
beliefs to express them and live by them
without anybody else stopping them from
doing so
so i think on in terms of
economics and liberalism
i think from my perspective when i think
of
you know what america stands for at
least in my mind
is economic opportunity and i define
that
as access to capital and then
on the on the kind of equality side it's
equal
equality under the law so the fact that
you know regardless of circumstance the
law treats
everybody the same but in terms of
economic opportunity
we have the ability to you have the
ability to essentially
chart your own path and what
what i've found at least in my studies
of you know where the united states is
going and where
you know in particular my focus has been
on china is going
is that there is a convergence um
away from this idea in the
in the united states of um
support for equality under the law
uh and and more which you i think you
describe in cynical theories as
kind of a triumph of liberalism
in the west so a move away from equality
under the law
um a move towards this idea that there
are groups
that because they have been previously
disadvantaged
that we should advantage them in other
words what you
what you should talk about in cynical
theories is this move away from
all men or all women or all humans are
created equal to
all humans are not created equal and in
fact some are more equal to others
is that is that a good in other words
what you say in cynical theories
is that in fact we're moving away from a
world where we were promoting
equality of mankind to one now we're
promoting racism is that
and that has been
that falls under these ideas of social
justice and critical race theory
and and all of these things that are
meant to up you know
when we say the words be uplifting
but in reality what you say in cynical
theories is that they're actually
corrupting
our this idea of equality under the law
is that
is that a fair characterization yeah yes
i think it is
um because it when we're looking at
liberal
ideas of equality these are consistent
principles of non-discrimination
but with the critical social justice
view
we have to believe in these invisible
systems
of power and privilege that permeate
everything
and they're called things like white
supremacy patriarchy
cisnormativity homonormativity sorry
heteronormativity
um in ableism fat phobia and these
permeate everything
and they cause us to privilege
some groups over others without even
realizing that we're doing it
and we need these kind of theorists to
make us see the systems
and to to shuffle them so one
of your most dominant theorists um
is of course ibrahim x kendi and
he has argued that discrimination
um is acceptable when it evens things up
so
if discrimination um results in less
racial equality then it is bad it is
racist but if it results in
more racial equality than it is
anti-racist
so he um is very much
taking this idea of um equity
on a racial uh level and this is
um that this is is in opposition to
liberal
ideas of um discrimination then
you have deangelo and she is focused
much more on these invisible systems of
power
and this leads to an inconsistency
where we it looks like double standards
people will say
this is hypocrisy surely uh what you're
saying is
is racist if you're assigning all of
these terrible con um
characteristics to to white people this
is racist
but that isn't how their system works
because they see it as
skewed so heavily towards certain groups
they want to
skew it the other way they want to
foreground
different ideas and they believe that
this will result in inequality
now james and i don't now james is an
american citizen
and he did on this um occasion vote
trump
um reluctantly because but because
he believed that in this the the state
of things at the moment trump
actually provided it's more of a
protector of a liberal
um consistency than uh
biden was i disagreed with him about
that
but i you know so that this is where we
are at the moment
we're trying to push back at these ideas
that we need to restore balance by
treating people
differently um with the idea that we
need to restore
balance by treating people the same
so i mean that's i think that's a good
point um
that you bring out between yourself and
james
the now but
when you think about it what kamal
harris and what joe biden have said
in regards to black lives matter which
essentially adopts many of the things
that you talk about
in cynical theories how do you reconcile
in your own mind
supporting them when you know that they
actually support
ideas that you repudiate in cynical
theories
i um
firstly there are a lot of other issues
as well so you're basically
prioritizing issues you're saying okay i
got i understand that they
support these things that i abort but
there's other things that they
that they promote that i support so
you're saying
you have a number of choices in terms of
policies
you're going to choose to focus on what
you believe
to be um i i would say in the economic
realm
and deal with the fact that
um you have challenges with their
support for things like black lives
matter
and um yeah there's
there's two issues there one of them is
that the
democratic platform is certainly a lot
more
than um the elements of it that support
critical social justice
and i think that on balance it is better
for
um american people than the republican
platform
but there's also the fact that biden
himself
is not a critical social justice
advocate he has said some
given some worrying lip service to it
but he has said that he will be a
president for all americans
now i was a huge fan of obama
and particularly the way in which he
criticized
um woke-ism and the idea that um
that you know if a black uh student
carrying a book is acting white he
he was what i would call a liberal
humanist
and biden as his vice president i think
did
well so i do not think biden is
this radical activist i think harris has
made some
alarming comments i'm um particularly
worried about
um aoc and her plan to
um create a list of trump supporters
which
sounds you know uh sort of approaching
yeah it's it's that's as we were talking
before this
my my whole um experience has been
focused on
china and the in particular the chinese
communist party how they have used
control of the narrative to define
truth within china and that has been a
very
um oppressive environment and what
you're what you're describing
is the beginnings it's at least it seems
on its face to be the beginnings of
something very similar
in the west and and i'm guessing
based on the fact that you're from uh
the uk
that it's not just in the u.s it's also
happening in europe and other
democracies is that
fair yeah that that's absolutely fair i
tried to attend a symposium called
decolonized stem
where i intended to argue that actually
saying that science and
and maths and and um stem generally is a
white western male thing is actually a
bit sexist and racist
and i was uninvited from this symposium
because my views would apparently make
everybody else unsafe
so yeah we have you're a very
threatening person
yeah i'm um i'm i'm terrifying
apparently so
yeah that we have the same problem here
it's not
as overt and i think to a certain extent
this comes down to a difference in
natural
in in national character americans
simply are more straightforward and
direct they'll
this is why i look a lot at what the
american theorists and activists are
saying
because they are explicit they will they
will come straight to the point here in
the uk
it's a lot more insidious you're less
likely to be
um called out publicly as as a racist
and um and yeah our politicians are less
likely to say really radical things but
you're just sort of
likely to get quietly sidelined fired uh
failed so we have the same problem
um with a different kind of character to
it and of course we have a problem with
critical race theory being imposed on
um uk culture where it it is even less
helpful than it is
in the us because it it simply doesn't
work we will hear
um anti-racists uh use the term bipoc
you know which means black indigenous
and people of color
now bipol doesn't work in the uk
indigenous britons are not people of
color
this isn't something that that that
makes any sense but it's being
transported wholesale onto our uh
political
it's been taken so a term that kind of
was
developed for the united states is being
impressed upon
the uk which has a completely different
um history yeah we have our own racial
problems
you know we have a very recent colonial
past in which we exploited
uh about a third of the world and so
yeah we have to deal with that but we
don't
most of the people that the uk um
exploited don't actually live here so we
have a different situation to the
ongoing
racial issues that you have in the us
and i i think i i have some sympathy
with a lot with some of your theorists
people like michelle alexander for
example
it is undoubtedly true that black
americans have
not had the opportunity to rise within
that capitalist system that that you
support
until a couple of generations ago so it
isn't really surprising that they
haven't
um caught up as a group yet and it's not
um i think unethical to look into
and support programs to to help them
actually do that right
i agree with that and and what i've
looked at
um since reading your book and
really coming to understand because i
think what it did for me
is solidify in my mind what was
happening in our country in terms of a
move away from
equality under the law to more of a
you know basically a racially segregated
society where
groups are you know essentially
more you know i guess truthful
or or speak more truth in other groups
because
they are more entitled their ideas are
more entitled or more
um help me out here they are part of a
group that
actually you value their truth more than
another group's truth is that
i mean that's essentially um one of the
the arguments that you make in cynical
theories that
certain groups should be more believed
than certain other groups
which is completely counter to equality
under the law
but what i have been looking at is
you know yes now we have equality under
the wall the law
and you make that claim with
regard to saying liberalism classic
liberalism has been successful
at providing a lot of social justice in
our country
but what has not been very successful
is on the economic side and so what i
found in looking at our relationship
with china in particular the chinese
communist party's ability to
utilize the globalized world and the
internet connected world to
achieve advantages for
their system over ours had actually in
the united states
led to the decline in economic
opportunity
that in conjunction with the monopolies
of the tech companies and other um
multinational corporations there's been
a consolidation of economic power
and access to capital frequently now
goes to
those large corporate systems or in the
case of
china the chinese communist party and
and so what has been going on here in
the country in this country the last
three years particularly since
after the first year of the trump
administration was this
effort to break apart this tie between
the chinese communist party their access
to capital and their ability to use that
access to capital
to incentivize corporations to do what
they want on the social justice side
so in a sense the two problems are
converging
because they are becoming one and the
same as
china becomes more part of the
globalized system
and as we you know in our
academic and political systems here
begin to adopt
this idea of one narrative there's only
one narrative that
is is the right narrative and all other
narratives
no longer have an opportunity to be
viewed and then as the tech companies be
able
or have been able along with the media
companies
to enforce the this narrative
that that one narrative then we're
becoming a
homogeneous international order
in other words you know we are we are
now
becoming much more authoritarian in the
west
and that's aligning very nicely with
the authoritarianism of of the chinese
communist party
and and in my mind the way that you
break that at least
is to create economic opportunity for
disadvantaged people
in the united states so those
traditionally that you mentioned
that have only recently had equality
under the law
but haven't necessarily had economic
opportunity
the way that we create a more perfect
union in the united states
is to help them have economic
opportunity and what i found in my study
is that the reason they didn't have
economic opportunity
is because access to capital was not
available to them
it was available to large corporations
it was available to the chinese and the
chinese communist party
but it was not available to the
small businesses that these
disadvantaged
groups tended to build and so they were
working
trying striving to you know
access the the benefits of society but
even though they had equality under the
law they didn't have economic
opportunity
on the other side of the pacific ocean
you had the chinese communist party
saying we'll give you economic
opportunity
meaning we'll give you access to capital
but you
must adopt the narrative that we give
you if you fight that narrative then we
can take away that
that economic opportunity so that's a
system they've created
what it appears to me is that we are
creating the system that as long as you
adopt
the narrative then economic opportunity
will be available to you
and the way that china is systematizing
this now is that you have a social
credit score
and so if you conform to the social
norms
and the narrative that the party wants
you to you can have access to capital
if you don't that access will be taken
away and so it's a self-equalizing
system an automated system is truly
automated because
you know you know it there's for example
for example there's two cameras for
every person in beijing they track
everything
that you do and that all everything that
you do becomes
scored and as your score goes up you
have more access
to economic opportunity as your score
goes down
you have less access and so when
so as i was studying that and i came
upon your book cynical theories i said
wow you know if you look at
um american universities if you look at
the american media complex if you look
at american corporations
and you realize that they are all
adopting these
critical race theories or other social
justice theories that
force you to adopt a narrative and if
you don't
they will withdraw the ability to have
economic opportunity
you see the beginnings of this alignment
into two systems and then
furthermore when you look at the
international order whether it's the
united nations or for example
in the united nations the the human
rights council within the united nations
and you realize a lot of these regimes
that don't actually
believe in human rights have you know
essentially gotten control of the system
politically geopolitically then now we
have this challenge
between what your book is saying and
what my book is saying about china
we are basically becoming one homogenous
system where
as long as you agree
with the narrative you're going to have
opportunity to the extent that you
don't then it'll be taken away that's
that's where you know i think it's such
an interesting thing that you've done
because you've taken
a very esoteric subject and you've
you've made it approachable
but you know i think
even when in this discussion probably
people are going to watch this and
they're going to say well i don't
understand
it's not clear to me and this is part of
the problem of
of this subject it has become so
esoteric in terms of
you know explaining these ideas can you
let's maybe bring it down a level and
say you know explain
to the audience why
an idea like the earth revolves around
the sun
is is it could be considered racist
because because everybody i i think
understands that the earth
the newtonian physics exists the earth
revolves around the sun i think that's
widely accepted in the west
yet in this idea of cynical theories
it it can be the the case like during
the you know medieval times where you
know the church said
you know everything revolved around the
earth and of course it took science and
and enlightenment period to actually
break that and a lot of people paid with
their lives
and were tortured for blasphemy but can
you explain that process because
i think people don't understand how
close we are to this
this idea where you're not allowed to
to dispute the you know what you
think or what you the narrative that
you've been given
okay so that there's a couple of things
um there and i i want to get back to
whether
um corporations are really
um so sucked into this ideology i i tend
to think that they
are not as much as they seem but before
that yeah i will certainly
um explain how this this idea
works so so we do know that the the
earth orbits the sun
we know that this corresponds with
reality
so in the post-modern um
view of the world there is
that there are regimes of truth um
is how foucault called it there are ways
we legitimize knowledge and ways that we
set that we don't
so we have decided that science
is a what is a legitimate form of
knowledge therefore
we believe physicists when they tell us
that the earth orbits the sun however if
we lived in a different culture and they
legitimized knowledge differently
as you were saying with medieval times
when and we're going with
um holy myths or you know some from
other parts of the world where
that the sun is a chariot being driven
across the sky by
a god that would be true because of the
way that
culture legitimated knowledge what they
say
is um oppressive is for us to say
the scientific way of um
deciding what is true correspondence
with reality
is superior to other ways of deciding
which what is true which can be
tradition
lived experience perception of of
certain groups and there's this idea
that because the world is believed to be
set up to work
for straight white men um you assuming
you're straight
um can see the surface of it
and you everything just looks absolutely
normal to you
now anybody who diverges from that um in
a different way
can see a bit more so i as a woman will
notice
sexist things which wouldn't be a um
wouldn't be accessible to you i i don't
actually notice them because
i i wouldn't see it because my own
language
prevents me from seeing it yeah
the world works for you so everything
just seems to make common sense
but if you were a black trans woman
um for example then you would see the
world differently because you'd be able
to see this
the systems of power and privilege that
you can't currently see
so this is what is dr idea that we need
to hear less from straight white men
and we need to hear more from
marginalized groups because they have
another kind of knowledge which is
equally valid
and of course that that simply isn't
true so this is what we argue
about as well this is called standpoint
epistemology where we believe that
people's knowledge is tied to their
identity
and that's related to their position in
power
uh but if you look at the sheer range of
um black intellectual thought on racism
you know if you were to look at angela
davis next to
thomas sal you you know this there is
you'd find it difficult to believe that
um there's a racial standpoint
that gives people the same experience in
the same views
so so this is a nonsense but i
i agree that the social justice
narratives it does have too much
um influence we are seeing it in
corporations we're seeing people
withdrawing products with
um apologies we're seeing google
technicians being
fired for pointing out the truth that
men and women have different interests
on average but that doesn't tell us
anything about any individual
we're seeing this affect corporations
but i
don't um believe that this
is because these organizations have
um legitimately bought into these social
justice ideas
there is significant concern among
um businesses and and you're quite
powerful businesses and people
are going along with these ideas
because they believe uh they quite often
they don't understand what they are
the diversity of training yeah so
here's a question for you um do you know
who lebron james
is um i've heard of him but no
yes so he's a he's a fairly famous
basketball player in the united states
so lebron james
is very much in the social justice
right but at the same time lebron james
refused to essentially
call out the chinese communist party for
oppressing the people of hong kong and
and so there and most
people believe and i happen to be one of
them that it's
that's associated with the amount of
money
that lebron james was making from sales
of his products
in china and so i agree with you
probably from the corporation
perspective there are people that
adopt these social justice ideas
but for the most part the corporations
are actually
doing it for more financial reasons and
and which is why i believe that
globalization in and of itself
unless it's curtailed and prevented
from essentially making profiteering
only about profiteering in other words
however you make the money
is okay as long as you make the money
when that supports these ideas
that in the only reason that you're
supporting is because of
profiteering for example if you support
the chinese communist party
in the suppression of the uyghurs then
the oppression of the people of tibet
and the oppression of the people of hong
kong and yet you claim to support social
justice
then in reality you're you're not really
being honest because that's not that's
not social justice but it's okay
because that's china and this is the
united states i think is
is part of the problem this is the
cultural relativism problem
yeah i mean the whole social justice
idea is
is rife with with contradictions we we
see it when
um there's a lot of emphasis on um
women's uh policing women's uh
dress uh expectations of women to dress
modestly
and then at the same time there's a
celebration of the hijab or even the
burqa
now you know they're not applying the
same rules
to the same groups because they believe
that essentially straight white men
have oppressed the rest of the world and
that we we cannot
um evaluate um anybody else so so we we
have
this real problem where it doesn't make
a lot of
sense we see a lot of support for black
lives matter
and um anti-racist stains
and then they try to lump this together
with intersectionality and social
justice more broadly
even though uh black americans are more
likely to hold socially conservative
views because they're more likely to be
religious
and they're less likely to support the
lgbt part of the social justice
thing so then we we have this but it's a
mess it cannot hold and it cannot work i
mean this is something i say to people
who fear that this really could go turn
into something like a communist um
uh regime i i think it's it's
too diffuse and contradictory it's
not as though there's this end goal of
um
seizing the means of production for the
proletariat there isn't
agreement that's what cynical theories
is about
is your attempt to fight it which was
what my book was about
you know our relationship with the
chinese communist party but broadly the
west relationship with the chinese
communist party
what i see happening here in the united
states in particular with this election
and you've said that you would support
biden if you were an american citizen i
said i supported trump
what's happening that i can see and it's
a very clear
i think microcosm of what we've been
talking about
say for example the media has already
called the election for biden
and essentially that
political group believes that biden
is president-elect yet we have
a number of uh voting inconsistencies
primarily because there was a lot of
voting by mail
which has been shown to be fraught with
fraud
and there's going to be a number of
legal challenges to the vote on the
basis of
there was either dead people counted or
there were
um votes from people that don't exist or
don't actually live in the state
whatever the issue is
there is there is a disagreement on the
vote so
how do we reconcile in the united states
the fact that we're going to have a
group that believes that they won the
election
and then we may go through a legal
process that says no in reality
uh somebody else won the election
here we're fighting a narrative here
we're
basically going along with
the rule of law how how do you think
americans
can come together and reconcile this
idea because
what i see going on right now is the
media has completely
basically gone over to one side in the
united states and i don't know what the
uk media is like but
when we when you talk about a plurality
of ideas there is not a plurality of
ideas
in the american media sphere today it is
one
cited completely now a lot of that has
to do with i think
animosity for the president but how do
we reconcile that as a nation where you
may have a legal process
that goes through and determines
somebody else's president but you have
this
this na this process of the narrative
that is creating
this alternative view how do we
reconcile that because i think
what you have brought in cynical
theories is
clarity to the problem but this is
becoming acute in our own society
right now like with in this election
so there's going to be an objective
truth uh
with the election if fraud has taken
place then obviously a
rigorous investigation needs to take
place
in the worst case scenario a new um
and more secure voting um sort of a
system has to
has to happen there's an objective truth
here this isn't a matter
of narratives i'm i'm somewhat skeptical
that the entire media is um
going one side because i i think the
last time i
i looked the most popular news outlet
is still fox you don't know what
happened recently so
fox was the first to call arizona
so all of its viewers are absolutely
up in arms because they believe
and there's been this slow uh
progression of fox news basically moving
more towards the rest of the um the mess
the rest of the you know msnbc cnn
all of the others and it's really broken
just in the last since fox news was the
first to call arizona before the ballot
all the ballots had been counted
there's a lot of anger and
disappointment in that so yes i would
agree that fox news was
but just in this election alone there's
been a complete shift
people are abandoning the channel in
fact recently cnn and msnbc
had more viewers than fox news which was
completely upside down so
um that that's happening like literally
right now which is why i say it's so
acute
i i certainly think there is that
dominant narrative problem
going on i i think there there are other
narratives in the us
as well though i hear a lot from from
conservatives who have their
their own very strong um narrative which
isn't
um always all that um healthy or based
on
evidence and reason either so i i
i still believe that the what the way
forward is for those of us
on the left or the right to focus
on liberalism to try and address the
problem on our own side now this is why
i have stayed
on the left and that's because i think i
have to fight
that problem within the left from the
left
and i appreciate and respect ethical
conservatives who see
the problem on the right so i um
i'm in favor of quite a lot of the the
never trumpers
who saw him as um what
i i think has been accurately described
as a post-modern president
is a very similar kind of problem
um epistemologically when when it comes
to how to
to knowledge and narratives that we're
seeing on the postmodern left
my my hope and i might be idealistic
here
is that uh liberal and evidence-based
leftists can push out the social justice
and liberal and evidence-based um
rightists can push out the populists and
and the grown-ups can
can talk and we can have two parties
again
who aren't based on um extreme
narratives and trying to win a war of
them now if you're asking me how to
achieve that and how to achieve it in
america
i'm not going to be um
i'm not going to be a miracle worker
here i have some plans for the uk
i think we are not quite where you are i
think we can pull back
i'm i'm quite scared for america at the
moment i'm
i'm afraid that that what is happening
is a genuine occult attempt at a
cultural revolution
and my fear is that it it could in its
worst case lead to something
that's almost like a civil war so i
don't know
how um you you can avoid
that i do think that you need ethical
um leftists in that to really hold
biden to his promise to be the president
for all americans and to try and push
that social justice
out of the left and to focus on
objective truth so i have to push back
on you just a little bit
because president trump did
ban critical race theory in the federal
government
so he basically i'm sure he didn't read
cynical theories
i don't think it's that that type of
president but he does get the idea that
this is actually
not good for america and so he banned it
with the federal government
so it it could be the case that biden
comes back in
if he is elected and there is no and the
legal challenge isn't successful
he could come back and reinstate
critical race theory
in the federal government and i think
you would say that's a bad idea
so it is so we've been discussing this
i'm
so i'm i'm in communication with a lot
of people
who are seeing the same problems on both
sides of the atlantic
now when president trump banned um
critical race theory i
said that that was a good decision i
supported his decision
to do that for the same reason that i
would have if federal
employees were being trained in
christianity or something it's a belief
system it's not like
it's like data protect right it's it's
literally like a religion
because it's not an objective truth it
is it is a narrative
that is irrefutable yeah so
that that shouldn't be nobody should be
forced to affirm that so
i was well i was a little bit concerned
about his language of um
teaching children to love america with
all their hearts and souls and i'm
wondering how they would do that and at
the same time cover
slavery and other problems um i
i do think that decision was a good one
of his and i do think
biden is likely to reverse it this
however has made
some um legal thinkers that i'm talking
to on
on your side of the pond think that this
gives us a new advantage
because a lot of what trump actually
um banned is already illegal so
it could be um actually a better
better strategically for people to be
able to bring
law cases against corporations if
corporations are in danger
right right it is biased it is going
against what would be under the law and
i think
you know to to to to go to the love of
america i think the idea and i'm not
president trump so i don't know for sure
but at least in my mind
respect for the constitution as a
as the abiding law of the country that
all
uh men and women basically people
are created equal and that they you know
have should have the opportunity to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
i think that's what he's getting at but
again who knows
i think you know some
a very positive narrative of america i i
think
it certainly already exists um because
if
if you look at the a lot of the social
justice people will want us only
to look at slavery and jim crow which
were undeniably horrific
but the progress that has been made
since these that that time i i
think is a very positive story of um
american pursuit for life liberty and
happiness
so yeah i think that certainly things
good can come from
from that but i think when there's a
genuine
risk and i don't deny it that
um we have less protection against
critical social justice ideas now that
there's a democratic
um president should that um come to
come to be and we're going to have to
redouble our efforts
to push back at that and i i think we're
in a better position to actually do that
from the left while they that that party
is
in power to try to restore
a liberal and much more sort of liberal
and
and support for freedom of belief and
speech this is something that isn't
the the kind of training that we're
seeing critical race theory
now it it simply it will try to
force people to affirm beliefs in things
they don't believe in which
is clearly unconstitutional and against
your first amendment
so there are a number of ways to get at
this and i assure you there are a lot of
people
and a lot of americans who are very very
intelligent
and very very organized and we and
we're all talking together about how to
to try to do this
well i i for one support you and will
support that effort in any way i can be
helpful
i would like to and i really appreciate
you coming on generally speaking
it's been a joy to talk to you i'd like
to talk to you again and
i think that you what we were doing is
so important to preserving our way of
life
in in in the free world not just in the
united states but everywhere
because it is really about educating
people about
what has been going on within our
particular humanities
and this activist applied post-modernism
which is really i think you would agree
destroying the fabric
of civil society in in the free world so
i i applaud you i really enjoyed talking
to you
i respect you and and thank you so much
for coming on generally speaking
yeah it's been good to talk to you
thanks for having me on
[Music]